it's the talk of County Fermanagh for
months people have been contacting a
local newspaper with allegations of
historical abuse one woman claimed her
child minder had sold her to pedophiles
and while she was left with this woman a
number of men yeah professional men some
businessman people after while no one in
the area were brought to the house over
a pair of four and a half years and
during that time they abused this little
garland from the age of four and not
only did they abuse her but they abused
other children as well the first man to
tell his story believes he could be one
of hundreds of victims child abuse on an
unprecedented scale he didn't want to be
identified but told us he'd been
repeatedly targeted from the age of 12
he was always on the road he was always
on the prowl for five nights a week he
was at various youth organizations
through the Klan take would you hazard a
guess of the number of victims that were
in this county I Taylor in the hundreds
and hundreds you can't you can't get
away with stuff like that there unless
you will some gain a power or some kind
of influence that the normal person
doesn't weigh they felt untouchable yeah
and they are untouchable because they've
got away with this for years the
revelations have stunned the rural
County with victims demanding answers
and justice police have established a
specialist investigation team other
parts of the responsibility of that team
is actually to go back over the many
years to look and see is there anything
there that maybe we didn't pick up on or
that wasn't followed through or is
connected in any way to the the reports
that are coming through now the
journalists documenting the abuse says
different people are naming the same
alleged perpetrators here we do know
that a number of people have worked
together to abuse children across from
on earth we're hearing a lot of the same
names and places we're hearing a lot of
similar incidents so we know that there
are lots of dirty secrets here that
finally being revealed in the tranquil
Lake lands of fermanagh a disturbing
picture is emerging alleged victims are
finally breaking their silence and this
community is asking how this could have
happened here
David Blevins Sky News in Enniskillen